Kip all.
Hello, everyone.
Dr. Paul.
Hey, how are you?
I'm good. How you doing?
Not too bad.
Yeah.
Hey, Mark.
Hey guys, Andrea will be with us in 5 minutes. She's just on the call.
Hello.
Okay, all good.
OK.
Support a lot of things have been.
Things have been great.
Yeah.
Right, nice.
Paul, there was one device, I don't remember the client and client name, but it was an RDS server, I guess RDS 01. Is that supposed to be managed by us or your team is handling that?
That's TDI. I think that's TDIC.
I guess.
I think that one's managed with a team here. It's not a very important server.
Okay.
Cool.
Andy.
Hey, Paul. Good. What is it? Afternoon.
Whatever it is.
So guys, Paul, anyone?
How are you?
Ah.
Sorry, go ahead, Vishal.
No, go ahead.
Yeah.
Is there?
I was just asking Paul if anyone else will be joining us today.
Nope, everyone else is either in meetings or customers. So you're, you only give me today.
Kour.
All right, I'm gonna quickly share my screen.
Okay, Paul, I hope you can see it now.
Yep.
Perfect. So Paula, as you know, that Riddle will be discussing the NOC services first, and then I'll pass on the slides to Andrea. She will be running the dedicated one. The agenda for the NOC one would be the SLA summary patch and backup compliance, and eventually true up and recap and to-dos.
If you talk about the SLA performance for April, things have been great. We received overall 58 tickets in April, and the resolution SLA for all the tickets is 100%. But for response, I said there was a miss in P2 category. So 3 tickets actually from P2 got missed.
from the acknowledgement. So they were delayed by two, 3 minutes, but that did not impact the overall SLA we have. If we talk priority wise for P1, we got 5 tickets, P247 alerts and P34 and two P4 alerts. All of them were acknowledged and closed within the time frame.
Nice.
So, if any any questions, Paul?
Nope.
Great.
If we talk about the patch compliance, the last patches were released on the 14th of April. Currently, we are sitting at 85.29%. New patches were released today, so that's why the numbers are low right now. And as you know, the patching is scheduled for 2nd and 4th Saturday. Currently, there are five devices which are showing pending patches.
Mhm.
A few of them will be taken care of this on the second weekend, which is this, I guess, yeah, this one. And the few one, TDIC, the main one, will be taken care on the 4th Saturday.
Gotcha.
If you talk about the backup compliance throughout April, we received two failure alerts. They both were acknowledged and closed within the time frame. They have backups are running fine now. Currently we are managing 8 devices for backup and for six clients.
Okay.
Moving on to the inventory, we are managing 20 devices right now. Any changes in this poll that we should expect on?
Um...
I don't think so.
I'll let you guys know when that changes.
Okay, cool.
All right, there were no to-dos from the meeting we had last time. Anything you want to add? Anything that you noticed either on the team chat for the team or any other thing that you want me to add here?
Now, things are going quite well.
Perfect, perfect.
All right, moving on to the dedicated services, over to you, Andrea.
Thanks, Vishal. All right, so just wanted to go through the highlights, Paul. So as for the team, just last night, as if we will officially join Granite taking room one, but making sure that we continue with the service continuity with this smooth transition. So we're going to take care of Katie.
We also had a discussion with one already, so we have that plan. I'll share that with you once we have that entire draft. Okay.
Okay, great.
All right, perfect. As for team member also, we wanted to welcome Anton back. So he has returned after a few weeks of hospitalization. So he's, we're glad to have him back and making sure that, you know, he continue his best performance to the team. So had to check in with him. He's pretty good. Had a bit of an issue with his,
Yep.
Hello, I think last week he was out, but he's feeling better now.
Right. Yep. Yeah, we're glad he's doing better.
Great. Next is client satisfaction. So both the engineer has been receiving positive CSAT ratings. This is reflecting their commitment to the service, the quality service and our partnership, just like what we talked about in the past. We're very, very on to making sure that our
your partners or your clients are well taken care of.
Kip.
Next is leadership. So I know that maybe there are some face here in this call that you're not familiar with. We had a different discussion last week, but I wanted to formally introduce you to Marky. So Marky has been appointed as the new technical team lead to this account, bringing additional structure and making sure that we work with Mon, Anton, and Sophia as well.
to make sure that we're moving forward. So if just like for everybody's understanding, Rodge has been moved to a more senior role, we're very happy for him. We wanted to make sure also that we still continue with the support for granted. I will not take Marky's thunder. Marky, introduce yourself.
Hi, Marky.
Hi, guys. Good day. Hi, Paul. Nice to meet you. So, yeah, guys, I'm Marky. And just to give you a background, I have 12 years experience in MSP, which is the background that I have. So previously, I'm working with First Focus IT, which is an Australian-based company.
I'm managing their After Hours team, which is a widely distributed team of 18 support staff members across Manila, Australia, India, Ireland, and South Africa. So aside from being the team lead for After Hours, I'm also doing the incident manager role for After Hours. So responsible for P1 and P0 tickets. Basically, it's an outage tickets. So I'm the one
Yeah.
I was doing the bridge calls from the client side and also from the support side of things. And not just that, I'm also doing the dispatch coordinator role for the After Hours team, which is responsible as well for assigning tickets to the team and making sure that all tickets that has been raised by VIP clients have been actioned in a timely manner.
Yeah, I'm looking forward to work with you guys and yeah, so for the best.
Good to meet you. Thanks, Mark.
Thanks.
Thank you, Marky. Next slide, please. There we go. Thank you. So just like what I mentioned, Paul, we're going to create that roadmap, training roadmap for Sophie, including what Mon does on a daily basis and what his outputs are, including ticket resolution as well as soon to be utilization as well.
So we're going to get to that. Marky will be able to help us as well in making sure that we create and send that over to you. Next is April CSAT for Manan and Tom. Have you received that email, Martha?
Yeah, and I thought I did them, but...
Gotcha. I think you did the NPS. I received the NPS for.
You might want to just resend them to me if I haven't done them. Okay.
I will do that. Sure. I'll resend it. I'll re-trigger it. Thank you.
Great, thank you.
All right, let's move on, please. Thank you so much. All right, so ticket closure trend analysis, I wanted to show Manan and Anton's average ticket close per day. So our target is 8 tickets A day. So for Manan, he was able to add, or he did demonstrate a strong operational control.
with consistently higher resolution rate, even during peak ticket volume. So this is making sure that whatever comes their way, he was able to close most of them, if not all. So as you can see on the numbers here, probably one or two to three tickets are being left and carried over to
the next day, but as for the resolution, he's been just being a rock star all in all. As for Anton, there was a slight dip with his ticket that has he has been handled and the average ticket closed. And this is not because of his performance. It's just that he was out for a few weeks. That's why it affected.
Mhm.
is his overall ticket members.
No worries there.
Yeah.
Thank you very much. So yeah, any questions on these?
Okay.
Got it. All right, so let's move on to CSAT. So customer satisfaction, their target is 95% is the score and response rate is a 30%, just that standard. And looking at the simple stat portal, Manan was able to achieve 90% CSAT for April.
which is a very, very good job. And I wanted to highlight something that was, I think, given by one of your client CEO, I think it's Diane. I was like, you just got a race, man. And then I was just teasing him. Come on, you're leaving us. I can't keep you in a race anymore.
Yeah, we got a good laugh out of that one.
Okay.
He gives a good review and he's leaving us, so now we're gonna we're just gonna delete that one.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Exactly, but just wanted to highlight it that for a CEO to actually take time and put a note out there just to highlight the service, that means Juan is doing something good. So just wanted to give him that kudos. Mass for Anton, he has achieved 65%, but no negative surveys, which is, I wanted to highlight also, again, there's a dip.
with how he's getting because of the weeks that he was away. But again, we had a discussion with him, Todd, and he's making sure that he's going to bounce back from that number. It's not a bad number, but he's going to.
How are we, how are you calculating that number?
the 65%.
For this.
just from the numbers that they get from.
From the total numbers, from the total number of the CSAT that they have.
Portal.
Okay, I don't remember any negatives coming in. So I actually thought I thought he gotten all positives.
Yes.
I just wasn't sure what 65% came from.
You're in mute.
Probably, were there neutrals as well?
Sorry.
No, there were no negative survey, right?
Neutrals.
There were no negatives, but yeah, the total number, I think, yeah.
Okay, how many, how many positive survey did he get?
Um, okay.
I think he only has 13 negative or positive CSATs.
Well, um...
One has 18 or 19, if I'm not mistaken.
Okay, I think we include the target score, which is the 95%, and the response rate of 30%.
Yeah, for the 95%.
I think from my perspective, they're actually both been running at 100% lately because it's been all positive scores.
So I didn't understand how you were calculating that. You know, when we get negatives, you know, I have to call the customer and we have to go through a whole rigmarole here.
Okay.
Mhm.
Mm-hmm.
And I don't remember any negatives for Anton, either of them, honestly, for, you know, for quite a while.
They're both doing great. Mine gets more tickets because he cherry picks.
Okay.
Yeah.
I'll tell him that.
I know he does. I tease him, I tell him I do.
Yeah.
Okay. All right. We have to check it out because I think we're including that response rate of 30%. That's why they're just getting these number. But if we're just after the score as an entirety of the CSAT that they get, then they should be getting 100% if there's no negative.
No.
Yeah.
I wouldn't, I wouldn't ding them on response rate just because customers respond or don't, you know, I can't make them do anything.
Yes.
Yeah.
Yeah, OK.
So we can just focus on the positive ones, not the response. Okay.
Pretty much, yeah. Yeah, if we get negative ones, we really want to drill into those and find out why. You know, those are those are very important. Obviously, we love the nice notes that, like what mom got, but you know, negatives are where we really kind of learn too, and we dig in and see, you know, what what didn't go right.
Just Kour, yeah.
Mm-hmm.
Mhm.
Yes.
and how to fix it. Almost always a communication problem.
Oh.
Okay, we'll think of it.
Gotcha, so we'll keep with the score, and then you know, with the response rate, just we can just keep that as a standard.
Okay.
Thank you. All right, let's move on. So way forward, I just wanted to put in that the Katie for Sophia. Katie process will be there. What will happen in the next two weeks? What are the things that she will be learning with the help of Manan also? Just making sure that right after that training,
she has an acknowledgement that she understand every process throughout the training. So that once she goes live and do shadow session or probably work with the tickets along with Manan, then there will be no problem. That's that. And I will get back. I did receive the email from Blaine as a follow up with the.
Right.
billing. So I'm making sure that I am actually accurately giving the accurate agreement for that. So I'm checking in with Natalie also with the CX team. So I'll get that sorted. Today, next is ITBD holiday, which is May 25th.
Sure, OK.
All right.
This is an ITBD holiday for Manila and the US. I just wanted to know if you guys are open at that time.
Is that, what's that one? Memorial Day. We are not working Memorial Day.
Memorial Day.
Yes.
Okay, so the three of them now can take that as an off, right?
Yeah, yeah. What day is that, Monday?
Okay.
Monday, yes, Monday.
Okay, good. Yeah, we are not working.
Cool, alright.
Well, let them know. Thank you very much. Do you need them to block their calendar?
LPSA.
Well, it's good practice just to block it out because customers can.
Okay, cool.
They can schedule appointments. Yeah. And some customer will probably schedule a Memorial Day appointment.
Schedule, data, all good.
OK, cool.
Because they don't think about it.
Okay, gotcha. All right, thank you very much. Vishal, want to take care of this or?
Sure.
I think we are good, Paul. As you know, the next slides will be just information on the other services we provide, our office locations, and the escalation matrix.
Yep.
I'll just stop the screen share now and open the forum for any last comments or questions, anyone.
So, yeah, I have a question for Paul. So, Paul, for the knowledge transfer or for the training for the new joiner, which is Sophie, based on one's information that has been provided, the training will take for about at least two weeks. So are you okay with that? Because I think the training will be
I have no.
Yeah, sure.
the documentation process that you guys have, the learning for the tools. And then after a week, I think Manu just going to do a shadowing for Sophie. Like Sophie will be the one who's going to create the tickets and Manu just going to guide him for a week.
Yep, that sounds fair.
All right.
As much time as she can get, all the better.
Okay, thanks.
Gotcha. We'll make sure that she's trained. Another one that I wanted to bring up, I think while we talked about building, wanted to know, are you coming? You should. No, not this time.
Alright.
No.
I shouldn't. No, I hate Jersey.
Yeah.
It stinks.
I was told. I was told.
Put in somewhere nice, and I'll go for that.
All right, but...
He.
I think they're, I think they're thinking of making, I'm not sure if it's finalized really, but I think they're wanting to do the event at, I forgot the place, Stock Exchange, yes, that one.
New York Stock Exchange.
And.
That would be cool. Yeah, that would be cool.
A lot true. Yeah, I think it's fancy. Yeah. Three coming, coming some with someone? No.
Yeah, but no, no.
Are you are you gonna be there?
He.
Yeah, I think so. I should meet you there. Yeah.
You are? You're stuck being there?
I can say, Paul, this call is recorded. Come on, so.
It smells weird. I don't like Jersey.
Yeah.
I'll keep that in mind.
Yes.
I'll come to the Philippines first.
You should. When?
Good.
Oh, I totally would. Hey, invite me over to Philippines. I'll do an event over there.
We'll do that. I'll make sure I'll be your tour guide.
All right.
Okay, I'll take that.
Yeah, I think that is pretty much it for Marky and I. Justin, have anything?
Oh, good for me.
Alright, well, thanks everyone.
Thanks, Paul. Thanks, everyone.
Thanks, Paul. Have a good day. Bye!
You too. Thanks, all.
Thank you. Bye.
Thank you, guys. Bye.